[Musik]
conan der barbar
hey wie gehts noch
ich will profi fußballer werden nicht
aber noch was dabei zum umziehen also
ich kann mich das wäre sinnvoll
[Musik]
der total kalt
was war das denn
weil gott wie finden sie eigentlich dass
dfl konzept oder hat man ihn dann
maulkorb verpasst was meinst du mit dsl
konstruiert dürfen wir auf den reden
hier finden sie das neue hygiene konzept
ihr macht das sinn jetzt so früh schon
raus zu gehen
es ist mode den fußball zu attackieren
aber wir müssen uns um ganz andere dinge
kümmern
ich glaube dass wir dass wir uns
generell gedanken darüber machen müssen
was wir daraus lernen aber es geht hier
nicht darum dass einzelne spieler jetzt
ihre gehälter bekommen sondern es geht
um zehntausende von arbeitsplätzen es
geht um mögliche insolvenzen von
vereinen an denen tausende von
arbeitsplätzen hängen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine körperproportionen sind scheiße los
keinen hintern in der hose
das ist eine völlig und sportliche figur
her
das sieht alles nicht so gut aus aber
das schlimmste ist dass du ihn überhaupt
keine technik hast du kannst den ball
nicht stoppen
du kannst nicht schießen ich wüsste
jetzt nicht was wir was wir was wir mit
dir machen
auf dem fußballplatz gute 20 viel
geredet aber bin ich jetzt geeignet oder
nicht nein
so jetzt habe ich den ball gekriegt mir
geht es sehr gut
ihr seid fc-fans nehme ich mal an ich
hab so ein eindruck ja wie steht ihr zu
geisterspielen ganz furchtbar
wir hatten jetzt schon 1 erlebt in
mönchengladbach und das ist wie auch
schon sechs ohne anfassen das ist also
wirklich
man hat auch ein bisschen das gefühl man
schaut einen playstation spiel zu kann
nicht die zukunft eigentlich hoffe dass
wir den mist auch bald verstehen damit
wir das nicht auf dauer haben also mit
uns ist es nicht abgesprochen bitte
hochzieht ihm wieder hoch
das ist ein wahnsinn bewusst weil du
bist ja wirklich das paradebeispiel
eines komplett unsportliche menschen der
unser gesundheitssystem langfristig
belastet mich auch noch irgendwas machen
berlin macht nur spaß ihren spaß auch
das ist das ironie allein auf deine
wegen der befragung würde ich dir den
doppelten krankenversicherungs
beispielhaften er macht nur spaß wenn du
jetzt in ein land gehen würde es wohl
fußballspiele manipuliert werden um wett
gewinne zu generieren dann könnte es
sein dass jemand sagt den lutz setzt
sich ihr ein super wäre das den
grundsätzlich ein weil das garantiert
mir keine ahnung niederlage oder sie
haben jetzt als beispiel niederlage
gesagt aber sie kann das nicht
garantieren weil du
also das weil du so schlecht ist dass
die mannschaft bei der dom mitspielt
verlieren wird
[Musik]
denn die vielen dank bitte gutes gefühl
aus ihnen wird noch mal ein ganz großer
gestützt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye